Darth Vader isn't just the most iconic
villain in the Star Wars universe he's
one of the greatest movie bad guys of
all time but there's still a lot to be
said about this legendary Sith Lord here
are a few things you might not know
about Darth Vader when it comes to the
most revisited roles in Hollywood Darth
Vader is right up there with the best in
terms of providing work for actors an
awful lot of folks have done time under
that big black helmet Darth Vader has
made official and unofficial appearances
in more than 200 different movies video
games and TV episodes once you include
parodies and cameos to give you an idea
of just how big a big deal Darth Vader
is consider that Han Solo has only
around 100 screen credits to his name
between the prequels the spin-offs the
games the animated series the trilogy
that started at all and Vader's various
crossover appearances he's not just one
of the most ubiquitous characters in
Star Wars related projects he's one of
the most recognizable pop culture
figures on earth which is kinda weird
considering he's barely in that first
movie that's right Darth Vader the most
iconic villain in all of sci-fi was in
1977 a new hope for just 12 minutes even
Chewbacca got more time in front of the
camera than Vader but those 12 minutes
were all it took to leave a lasting
impression and create a villain whose
legacy will last for generations while
Anakin Skywalker might be known for his
intense emotional anguish Vader himself
has another cross to bear outright
physical torture and most of that came
courtesy of his armor underneath his
sleek cyber suit are several layers of
rotting flesh that never healed after
his fateful lava bath on Mustafar oh man
I just don't get this you know it's not
easy to find things to match this mask
as you might expect the nerve damage to
Vader was pretty immense and he is
forced to take all kinds of numbing
agents and sanitation baths on the
regular there's also the fact that his
helmet is bolted to his head and
continually Pierce's him with needles to
keep his mind synched with the suit
basically not a second of Vader's life
goes by without him having to endure
searing pain his constant torture
however allows him to drown in his anger
becoming a stronger Sith Lord with every
passing day when you think about it any
evaders numerous enemies
could have taken him out pretty easily
if they managed to get the jump on him
during his weaker suit list state and
it's a testament to his power and Menace
that nobody ever did
while tradition tasks the Jedi with
crafting their own lightsabers the Sith
tend to undergo a much darker ritual to
create their red lightsabers Sith Lords
have to steal a Jedi's Kyber crystal
warping the once benign object with rage
fear and loss basically all the buzz
words of the Ceph 2018 s Darth Vader
comics revealed that Vader stole his
crystal and hilt from a Jedi named key
rock in Fila
but this original iteration of the
weapon as shown in the comics isn't the
one fans have come to associate with
Vader after using the Jedi stolen hilt
for a while he eventually crafts one
that matches up much better with his
tech driven armor the change in the
weapons aesthetic isn't by choice though
bounty hunters almost destroyed Vader's
stolen saber during an attempt on his
life
Palpatine explains the process to his
apprentice by assuring him that there
isn't any real difference between the
blades of the Jedi and the Sith except
that the crystal that powers the Sith
version of the weapon as he puts it has
been made to bleed despite taking his
saber in thus if approved manner however
Vader's fighting style is actually
pretty unique this comes across in the
movies too Darth Vader's two-handed
lightsaber swordplay tends to be far
more brutal than other Jedi and even
more brutal than his younger self as a
young Jedi Anakin Skywalker favored the
same form 5 lightsaber technique that
Luke Skywalker would one day use against
him but once Anakin became Vader he
modified his form 5 style to accommodate
the limitations and channel the full
power of his life supporting armor for
Vader choosing to build his imposing
castle on Mustafar was less about
marking his spiritual birthplace and
more about lamenting the loss of his
wife Padme in Darth Vader issues 22 to
25
Vader begins building the first version
of his castle with the help of Sith Lord
momen whose spirit is contained inside a
helmet that Palpatine had given his
apprentice momen promises that building
a castle on Mustafar would give Eider
the chance to make contact with his lost
love so with the dead Seth Lords help
Vader construct several different
designs of his fortress on the site of
his greatest defeat after a battle with
the locals and a sudden yet unsurprising
betrayal from moment
Vader sends his assistant back into the
abyss he then succeeds in his mission to
cross the veil between life and death
departing from his body and going on a
journey into the force itself here
Vader's spirit melds between his life as
Anakin and his current state as Vader
and he even receives a few fuzzy
snippets from the future he finally
reaches Padme though whether it's her
spirit or Vader's memory of her isn't
really clear unfortunately for the Sith
Lord she immediately rejects him
insisting that Anakin is dead and that
she doesn't know the man standing before
her Padme then plummets into an abyss
afire and Vader is finally forced to let
her go which was most likely Palpatine's
plan all along
for decades fans have debated whether or
not grand moff tarkin knew of Vader's
former identity as Anakin Skywalker the
Clone Wars series shows Anakin fighting
alongside Tarkin where he witnesses the
young jedi skills and his deep
relationship with the force a mutual
respect forms between the two before
either became entangled with the Empire
the canonized novel Tarkin takes the
theory a step further however as the
Imperials dude moles over the
similarities between Anakin and Vader at
one point Tarkin outright theorizes that
Vader may well be the Jedi Knight Anakin
Skywalker later in the novel Palpatine
queries whether Tarkin knows the secret
and uses it to test his followers
loyalty and Tarkin passes the test as a
regional governor he could have done
anything with this information but
chooses to keep silent instead
subsequently Tarkin becomes the only
character to have shown any kind of
genuine respect for both Anakin and
Vader
despite his skepticism of the force Leia
Organa was the first of the Skywalker
twins to meet Darth Vader in a new hope
so it's only fitting that she was the
first to face him in battle on the
planet of rogas vas in the 2016 comic
storyline Vader down Leia orders the
rebels to drop a fleet of y-wing bombs
on Vader the showdown takes place
between the aftermath of New Hope and
the beginning of the Empire Strikes Back
fresh off the back of the destruction of
Alderaan
and while the film's never adequately
address Leia sense of loss when Tarkin
and Vader destroyed their home planet he
or she is willing to die to avenge her
people and her family when c-3po points
out that or during the bombing of Vader
will certainly kill Leia too she accepts
it willing to do anything to bring down
her
obviously though latest attempt on
Vader's life fails quite dramatically
and Leia's father lives to fight another
day
before he succumbed to the power of the
dark side the young anakin skywalker
created the fussy squeamish droid fans
know as c-3po unfortunately he also
simultaneously created one of the more
notable plot holes in the Star Wars
universe if Anakin made c-3po why didn't
he recognize the droid when they ran
into each other during the original
trilogy well in the now-defunct legends
continuity the two do actually have a
reunion of sorts in the comic thank the
maker Vader finds three POS disassembled
body on Cloud City and shares a brief
tender moment with his old droid but
even in Disney's new Canon these two
have a connection that goes beyond the
movies in the comics star wars 75 the
Sith Lord finds himself helping his old
creation albeit unknowingly in a
selfless effort to deep power a set of
bombs in an earlier issue c-3po elects
to face deactivation himself to save a
planet and the rock creatures living
there meanwhile Vader who was injured in
a scuffle retreats to tend to his wounds
when Vader uses an energy blast to power
back up key unwittingly revives his old
droid unraveling a slight easter egg
reference to his origins the c-3po says
thank the maker as Vader's blast
breathes life back into him if only he
knew how right he was
it's not exactly a secret that George
Lucas was telling fibs when he claimed
to have plotted out every major detail
of his Star Wars saga from the beginning
between the many continuity
discrepancies and early scripts popping
up over the years fans have debunked his
claim repeatedly taking a step beyond
speculation an actual deleted scene from
a new hope sheds further doubt on
Lucas's claim in an extended version of
the scene in which Luke reunites with
his old buddy Biggs red leader reveals
he once met Luke's father I Met Your
father once when I was just
there's a great pilot you've got half
the skill he had to do all right
red leader isn't exactly forthcoming
with any information regarding where he
met Luke's father so you could
technically argue that it still works
for continuity sake for example he could
easily have met Anakin before he turned
to the dark side
since few people knew that Anakin was
Vader those who remembered the former
Jedi likely assumed that he was dead and
red leader could well have figured out
the connection between Anakin Skywalker
and Luke Skywalker then again that
doesn't account for the fact that Anakin
Skywalker's ghost actually shows up in
an early draft of the script for the
Empire Strikes Back
all in all it's probably best to just
assume Lucas has been Indiana jonesing
it from the beginning
[Music]
Darth Vader's game-changing revelation
at the end of the Empire Strikes Back is
one of the most misquoted moments in
cinematic history when Darth Vader
responds to Luke's accusation that Vader
killed his father no I am your father
countless fans must remember the quote
as Luke I am your father
the site LOVEFiLM calm once pulled over
fifteen hundred film buffs to determine
which misquote rules the galaxy survey
says it's Vader's reveal even James Earl
Jones himself says the line incorrectly
in the documentary Empire of dreams the
story of the Star Wars trilogy of course
you can kind of see why the misquote
came about it contextualizes the scene
in question and makes the sentiment even
more personal and dramatic given the
Skywalker's flair for the dramatic it's
almost a shame that the altered line
isn't the canonical version in fact
since the wrong quote is so ubiquitous
there's a good chance that a lot of fans
will have heard the incorrect version
before they've even seen the movie
making the actual reveal somewhat of a
letdown
although Vader's appearance midway
through rogue one a Star Wars story was
written into the script from the get-go
his more famous scene was very much a
last minute addition everyone knows this
scene by now it's the intense hallway
battle sequence in which a BC's ship
full of rebels raced to escape with
their stolen blueprints for the Death
Star while Darth Vader hunts them down
this sequence has since become a fan
favorite made that much more remarkable
by the fact that it was tacked on at the
last possible moment after the editor on
rogue one argued that Vader needed more
screen time as director Gareth Edwards
explains we were cutting the film
together
and my editor jay-bez Olsen he said I
think you need one last moment with
Darth Vader like one more badass moment
with him but the timeline to get this
scene done was extraordinarily tight
according to Edwards when he mentioned
this it was about four months maybe from
release ultimately the sequence was shot
in three days an incredible feat for a
last-minute edit that ended up being
among the most memorable scenes in the
entire film what's more every movement
Vader makes in that scene is totally
faithful to his past appearances as
Edward says I think the golden rule was
not to let Vader do anything that hadn't
been seen or established in the original
trilogy as a result Vader wields his
lightsaber and uses the Force to choke
his foes all stuff
had done during those first three films
there certainly wasn't any of this going
on for most of the original Star Wars
trilogy the man behind the mask was
David Prowse a bodybuilder who's six
foot five inch build was perfect for
bringing Vader's imposing physical
presence to the screen but thanks to an
unfortunate communication breakdown
between Prowse and George Lucas the
actor apparently didn't realize that his
voice would be replaced by James Earl
Jones in post-production and he wasn't
exactly happy when he learned the truth
Krause was rumored to be difficult on
the set there after refusing to learn
the lines for the Empire Strikes Back or
Return of the Jedi and his feud with
George Lucas eventually reached the
point at which Krauss was no longer
invited to participate in events with
the rest of the cast
however Prowse does deserve credit first
contributions to the series particularly
the climactic scene in which Darth Vader
redeems himself to save Luke the
athletic actor needed only one take to
pluck the Emperor off the ground and
pitch him overboard unfortunately you
can definitely see why Lucas wanted to
dub over Krauss his voice while the
bodybuilder had the perfect build to
play Vader his speaking voice which was
high-pitched and West country accent
'add didn't fit the bill at all if
you're wondering what lord Vader would
have sounded like as an Englishman there
are a few pre dub scenes still floating
around that feature Proust speaking
Vader's lines
was that I knew the royal family on
board okay
Carrie Fisher in true Carrie Fisher
fashion even began referring to prowess
onset as Darth farmer it's not exactly
terrifying the drama between Lucasfilm
and David Prowse extends further than
onset shenanigans and a ban from
official events though Krauss had a
minor appearance in the documentary the
People vs George Lucas which interviewed
fans and people officially affiliated
with Star Wars encouraging them to gripe
about Lucas failings in this documentary
Prowse discusses the idea that the
franchise sold out to make money in
merchandising saying Return of the Jedi
was the beginning the merchandising
raised its ugly head and then the whole
thing became super commercial from then
onwards according to The Daily Beast
however Prowse didn't even know the
purpose of the documentary it's entirely
plausible that the filmmakers didn't
give any background on the project as
they appear to have interviewed him on
the fly in the middle of an autograph
line the film cuts out any prelude to
Prowse his answer
making it possible that the interviewer
insinuated the desired response within
the question without much context mark
hamill almost suffered the same fate
admitting to vulture
I almost got hornswoggled into that
documentary they weren't calling it the
People vs George Lucas at the time but I
could tell from the questions they were
asking me that it was an open invitation
to trash George Return of the Jedi
producer Howard Kazanjian claims that
only three completed scripts of the film
ever existed they belong to Lucas
Kazanjian and director Richard Marquand
regarding Krauss has access to sensitive
dialogue in the script cos engine says
for delicate information lines he would
simply count one two three four or read
a fictitious line and character to the
real dialogue but this secrecy didn't
save brows from paying the price for
leaking Vader's death to a tabloid
according to Prowse a reporter contacted
him at the gym to set up an interview
about his weightlifting career but the
journalist turned the tables on the
actor telling him that Vader was getting
killed off the reporter also claimed
that another actor would appear behind
the mask
when Prowse looked at his call sheet it
read Dave Prowse Darth Vader studio 1
and sebastian shaw anakin skywalker
studio 10 just one day after the
interview the Daily Mail published an
article revealing Vader's death
suggesting that Kraus himself had leaked
the information decades later the
documentary I am your father set the
record straight
getting the journalists to admit that
Proust didn't spoil anything and that
the leak came from another source but
the massive spoiler was the final straw
for Lucasfilm his stuntman Bob Anderson
mostly donned the Vader armor and Return
of the Jedi and Prowse was nearly cut
out of the movie altogether the final
betrayal for Prowse however came in the
form of Vader's helmet reveal because
when a redeemed Anakin Skywalker looks
on Luke with his own eyes it's not
Prowse his eyes that are doing the
looking actor sebastian shaw appeared in
the small scene a slap in the face to
Prowse who was under the impression that
he would be unmasked at some point
during the series to make matters worse
proust old equity magazine that he still
hasn't received residual payments from
Return of the Jedi because it hasn't
made a profit and added if there's a pot
of gold somewhere that I ought to be
having a share of I would like to see it
despite the drama however prowl still
has a positive outlook on his Star Wars
experience as he told the void well I'm
grateful for
everything that's happened to me from
Star Wars it altered my career
completely check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you